hello guys my name is Jenna and welcome
to episode 19 of the Sparky Gammage and
series in which we create a beautiful
non-working engine from scratch in C++
let's fix this bug I don't know how I
managed to my memory must have been
pretty clean last time because it did
somehow manage to read a memory address
of zero for the texture but we had a
problem where if you if you probably
would have had this problem if you
pulled episode 18 from github but
there's an access violation somewhere we
tried to get the texture ID here and
it's resulted in failure so let's switch
to debug mode and see if we can get any
more information actually know what the
problem is I'm just pretending but it
should be good so you can see that we're
in textured age and we're getting an
access violation basically it's like i
want to access i want to access mt ID or
wait there's no memory allocated for
that field disaster so that means that
our m texture which of course has this
great system of if it's null then let's
return 0 it's obviously not equal to
null pointer somehow it should be but
it's not so it is going to this
condition and trying to get the ID or
something but actually is null so what
is null but this is failing because if
you hover your mouse over you can see
it's 0x cbcb anyway it's not 0 where the
memory just isn't 0 but you can see that
it doesn't actually exist unable to read
memory right so we need to fix that so
basically the problem is that we're
never actually instantiating m texture
to null pointer it's just some it'll be
some random value we're just reading
something that doesn't exist so what we
should do is when we create and this is
just that yeah so in every constructor
you can just do this here of course you
can set m texture to null pointer okay
so let's make sure that we're doing that
and we've got one more constructor here
so don't forget about that one and I'll
just do this all right really important
and it'll fix us up if we run this now
it should be the best ok there we go
it's all working one thing we should
probably say as well is that I mean I
don't know why I write this it probably
makes more sense like this if it's null
pointer we're easy
doing this but we could have just done
if M texture then this otherwise zero
and that probably would look a bit nicer
so basically it's saying that if it's
not false and false would be if it was
zero which is null point and non point
is just zero basically so if it's zero
which means it's null return sorry if
it's not zero return this otherwise if
it is zero then zero so if we're on this
it'll have the same result but probably
looks a bit cleaner okay cool
there we go so yes so it's pretty cool
client how like in C++ you can kind of
pass in an object as like an if
statement thing obviously it's not an
object it's just a pointer so it is a
memory address so you're saying
basically if M touches 0 if it's not all
you'll have that and if it's not now
you'll have like some kind of memory
address right which would default to
being true because anything that's
greater than and here's an all zero is
basically true anyway um enough about
that let's actually get on with the
episode I'm just amazed that I managed
to actually push that push that broken
code but let's talk about how how our
font rendering is going to work so you
let me yeah one debug very good last
time we created well we didn't create
anything actually we got free type and
freed up GL to work they're part of our
project because of M scripting them
because we actually need to compile them
for the web and convert them as
JavaScript using M script in the future
that's why I put them here but more
importantly they're totally working now
we need to use them to render basically
font using our batch renderer so we
could create a brand new renderer that
just deals with fonts that's not an
ideal situation we remember a batch
render just renders a bunch of stuff so
there's no reason we shouldn't be able
to submit font fonts to it and also if
we do stuff like there's a few if we
have it as a separate render it means
it's going to be completely separate
layer which means it's going to have
separate uniforms is going to be it
could use it could use a same shader
obviously but it needs to it needs to do
a variety of things that just aren't
good and then if you want text to be
behind say a few sprites you can't
actually do that unless you put the
whole layer behind anyway there's well I
guess yeah you could probably just um
yeah there's a few worried well yeah he
could you could do that let me take that
it's not back because he could just
change the Z value but in a 2d scenario
right you do want to basically submit
things in a particular order and that is
kind of the rendering order right anyway
all that aside we need a system to
render fonts into our batch renderer so
let's open up mischief and begin
planning this out
so here's our scenario I want to be able
to somehow we I don't know from where I
just want to be able to this is our end
result I want to be able to call door
draw string okay I want to specify a
string such as hello right I want to
specify an x and a y and I want to draw
that okay
that's my scenario I probably want to
somewhere set a font possibly in here I
actually you know what I probably want
to have a color so like pink because
that's like the best yeah and maybe
somewhere else there'll be some kind of
way to set a font or something like that
I don't know it might even take a font
in here or something not sure but
basically this is what we're aiming for
we want to be able to do this how will
we do this
well our layers are in charge of pretty
much everything to do with actual
graphics but they're like the high level
version of a renderer right so they kind
of organize us so layer should probably
have a drawstring which will probably
send the appropriate data that we need
such as the texture I guess it needs to
work out all the vertices will probably
actually have a drawstring in the
renderer which will do all this would
would will figure out vertex and texture
coordinates and all this other stuff
like kerning and you know appropriate
spacing between characters and all about
fun maths that we need in order to
render fonts we'll get the renderer to
probably do that but the layer will
probably have drawstrings since we don't
have access to a renderer
we only have access to a renderer
through a layer remember that's why I'm
going to do it through layer so we
should probably have a renderable which
is going to be essentially a font right
so a renderable will make a renderable
called like label for example
okay now label will again it will take
in probably a standard string right it
needs to take in and an X in a Y
position and will give it a color as
well right so it's got all this data
since it's a renderable it has yes it's
got the position size isn't necessary
because remember all we're going to do
is in the ran durables submit method
which is what it uses to so submit takes
in a renderer as you probably remember
it takes in a renderer and what it's
going to do is it's going to be like oh
I want this renderer which will call our
to just simply control me a string okay
so that's how it's going to work
so we'll submit we submit labels which
are basically just strings of text to
the layer as if it were any other
renderable it's just that it's a
particular renderable that happens to
take in say this in the constructor okay
now the cool thing about this is that it
that means that if we do it this way it
will work with groups that's another
reason I should probably mention that we
should actually use we should actually
get the bash renderer to do this rather
than creating a whole new renderer
because remember if we're in a layer and
we're trying to make say a button and a
layer has a obviously to make a button
with text inside order we'd use a group
wouldn't we so we have this group which
has this bap of this button maybe some
kind of background and then text now if
this text is in a different renderer we
can't have it in the group we can't have
it relative to say this point over here
anymore can we so that's why it's really
important to to do this in the batch
render okay in fact every renderer
should probably have something like this
obviously if you have like a 3d kind of
3d like scene renderer which we will
have eventually
that doesn't need a font that need that
doesn't need to deal with like
drawstring because it's is you can you
can't do that right it's it's not
something you can do because it's 3d and
it doesn't deal with stuff like text if
you want text in 3d and you actually
want 3d text well just use a 3d model or
something right it's it's um it's
nothing to really require but something
like a bash renderer or any any kind of
2d renderer which will potentially be
used for GUI needs to have this here
right needs to be able to render these
things called labels one thing I should
also mention is that batch renderer is
our predominant 2d renderer there's
really not too much need for there's
really not much need for a different
renderer because again we do have that
simple renderer which was basically just
there for kind of educational purposes
right as in there is no reason to ever
use this it's not better in any way in
fact right now it's incomplete and
broken because we did add so many
different things like textures that it
just doesn't support so what I'm saying
is our battery Android is essentially
probably our only 2d renderer right so
we can kind of with that in mind we can
kind of be a bit be a bit more relaxed
about what gets supported in how stuff
gets done but that is out that is our
plan ok so I like to plan these things
out because a again I haven't actually
implemented this in Sparky before so I
don't know what I'm doing right this is
going to be kind of new ish for me as
well because I'm good so it's beneficial
for me to plan this stuff out so I know
what I'm doing but also it's it's a it's
it's a really good habit to get into
planning up planning out what you're
actually going to do before you do it
because it will make you much more
efficient and it will prevent you from
rewriting Toto too many times right so
back in here let's go into one thing
okay so next episode I'm probably gonna
I'm not gonna do this now but in the
next episode which is the maintenance
episode I will probably I will probably
just saw this out into folders because
we were using the show while files thing
before but
I probably shouldn't have been doing
that that's why we did have stuff like
buffers and layers these are physical
physical folders on our hard drive
whereas these are just filled studio
folders that are actually exist so we
might just want that so we'll go and
show the last one I'll anyway in
graphics I'm going to add a new item
called
label so we'll start with the high level
stuff just because it'll be easy and it
will set the scene for us one thing I do
want to mention is a really good
strategy when you're trying to implement
something complex or something new
really is to basically just write out
how you're going to do it so exactly
this this is this is my n scenario this
is my this is how I want to use the API
right that's what I want to do I want to
be able to call label drawers as I um Oh
our lair write drawstring with these
parameters and and it's gonna take care
of the rest
right so with that in mind we know that
layer needs a drawstring method and we
want to instead of doing this or
whatever this might actually create a
layer
sorry this might actually create a label
but we want to be able to just go layer
right dot add and then our label that's
kind of the plan that's the master plan
and then this might be something else
that we do I'm not sure that might be a
quick and dirty way and then the layer
itself might actually create its label
and submit it normally so that this
might just be a wrapper for creating a
label right anyway in our label I'm
going to go ahead and not existing
whoops I'm going to go ahead and create
an h-file pragma once a head of file I
should say let's grab our oh no I called
it Leia and it totally let me that's
cause it's in well okay I'm just gonna
remove it because I don't like visual
Studios renaming stuff label ok label
take to parag my wants namespace class
label so remember it's going to be a
renderable 2d include renderable Trudy
ok so it's going to have a few extra
things Ryan such as a string we can just
call this like M text or something like
a label will have text right it will
have a vet - I'll have a vector3
position and that's just for easy
submission you know it already does have
a physician because it's a renderable so
it has the position total sides it's got
a color which is fantastic it probably
should have something like a you int
color we might switch to that in next
episode of something like that texture
it warned me so that'll just be null
pointer of course everything else is
pretty good okay so so back here so
we've got that and that's pretty much
all we need apparently now the font that
we used is probably going to be up to
the renderer that shouldn't be the case
but that's going to be the case for now
okay we might deal with multiple fonts
or something in the future okay the way
that we probably specify font is we
might do something like you could
probably load in your own font as well
and there might be something like a font
manager and then if you once you load in
your font you probably will pass maybe
like a name such as I want to use Arial
and we'll probably just you Daryl today
or something
so that's the idea we'll use a few fonts
today obviously we want to make sure
everything works but when you create a
label you want to pass in a string it
can be contrarians it doesn't matter
we're going to copy it anyway so we've
got a string called text we've got a we
want a flirt X and flirt Y and then we
want a color which looks like it's going
to have to be a thing yeah I guess it's
going to have to be a I'm really going
to switch to the new method though it
has to be a vector for right now color
okay now it's going to override submit
obviously so we're submit here it is
let's grab that quickly going to
override this and that's probably enough
for now at least so let's start
implementing this stuff
okay label label let's grab all that
parameters from here okay so so M text
is going to be text M position is going
to be XY 0 and then M kala is going to
be color that's all we need to do so
what's wrong with text I got this what
that's wait a minute
oh we shouldn't we shouldn't do that
which probably run the constructor hang
on a minute hang on a minute that's not
the right button where's our renderer
renderable okay so we specify position
size cut yes we don't really want to do
this I don't need to set UV default yeah
mmm we will call so I guess we will do
something like order him to render a
bowl 2d so we'll pull the construction
will do all this stuff why you why are
you annoyed it's not remember up based
class what mm-hmm This Is It this is
weird it's being in the wing I guess
what does happen this way then yeah you
probably can't use initialize with that
stuff although I don't remember if I
have an old okay let's quickly caught
that in pulpit here so in position oh
that's probably why actually maybe
because I forgot the
Mass Effect 3 no apparently not okay
let's let's just do it here
not that it matters as they're not that
matters to us it will fix it but we
don't care how it works that's totally
fine
okay mmm so always gonna say yes so
anyway that's done let's quickly pop in
our submits renderer to the renderer
right that is our and and Const yeah
okay so what we want to do is we want to
call renderer dot draw string text XY
color I guess I mean that's probably and
then the renderer will handle the rest
I'm guessing I don't really think
there's too much that we have to really
do I guess not and remember since this
right now since this is this label is a
renderable it should just we don't even
have to change the layer right now
unless we want that that that drawstring
like kind of additional kinda wrapper
method so in our renderer in in any 2d
renderer right so in renderer 2d alright
let's go ahead and go a virtual void
draw string so we'll take in the string
that we're draw the string that we're
drawing as a constable reference so I'll
hold its text bullet strength that could
be confusing I'll call it text X Y and
the remember the size will be dependent
on the font by the way so some something
we do here that's doing it on the font
yes so what should I say color so we'll
have to convert the color into yes we'll
do that eventually and that should also
be a conference ok cool there we go so
there's our drawstring beautiful let's
copy that and pop it into batch render A
to D none of my shortcuts work here
because I'm used to a visual assistant
that is not here because I'm trying to
be all free for you guys and not using
stuff that that you can't get free
okay so let's pop that in here and
finally our batch render has a
drawstring okay so now it's time to
actually start using free type GL and
free type right so in fact we just need
freed up GL so if I go out into battery
under H let's put them here
we need to include so we could add it to
our include path okay that's totally
okay I'm not going to do that though
we're just going to go back to here go
into ext free dive GL and recharge yell
dot H okay so we're including it now
arrows everywhere I don't want it we'll
deal with us we'll deal with that when
the time comes let's just build it
actually and let's see if they're real
ours okay so there are here what's this
all right of course what do I done
positioned X
so I guess we could just give it a
factory or something right that will
probably make more sense so it's got a
position and one on I'll go ahead and go
to renderer and change this to be a
Const maths BEC 3 position
I won't pop that into batch render oh of
course you guys know the drill okay good
so there we go
yeah so let's build this and see what's
up there's a lot of errors so they're
rolling W glue huh
so what's including that we shouldn't
need that we just used normal glue so
let's see what is including that opengl
okay so it's including both for some
weird reason let's just get rid of that
okay great so now this stuff is
ambiguous because because freetype does
it freed up GL does it right where's
free type GL I need to talk to you you
are naughty free type GL so using
namespace ft GL so uh how about no how
about how about you know okay no errors
Oh errors
that's my bad though drawstring class
what are we still that's really hard to
read Novak three constant okay that's
weird
oh yeah we're not we haven't implemented
it so what I should have done was just
had some empty brackets so yes so as
opposed to forcing it to happen it will
just do nothing right so I could have
made it pure virtual which means that it
would be forced to be implemented right
so kind of like an abstract
an abstract method in Java which is in a
non abstract class so sorry that made no
sense if you inherit an abstract method
you have to implement it unless your
class is also abstract or if it's an
interface you have to implement it
analyze the cost unless the class is
abstract so in this case yes it means
that if is equals zero you have to
implement it you have to implement it in
the in class at your that your sub
classing from this right
so without the equals zero means you
don't so I don't have to implement it in
simple renderer for example that's why
this error what was happening because I
wasn't it well it wasn't equal zero
which meant that it needed to be
implemented in this class but it wasn't
anyway let's bill doesn't see that error
go away okay great and how build times
so long now well they aren't that long
obviously but they're like a few seconds
which is annoying that's because of all
this stuff anyway that aside let's go
ahead and get into this and start
seriously doing things so I'm just gonna
hit up using namespace f tgl right so if
we type GL of course so this is going to
this this is the difficult part okay I
say it's the difficult part because it's
not easy so we need to do a few things
we need to F T G L so we want a texture
Atlas and we want to font so we make an
Atlas that's the idea so M Atlas I'm
gonna say three type Atlas right and
then M three type fonts
and I think that's all well need so this
is going to oversee be a font okay so I
believe that the way that gets created
is there's a nice create method wolf
we'll find it in a minute
that does it stuff so we need to do this
in the constructor so in in it right
which is right over here at the end of
all this stuff we can go ahead and
initialize our font so we'll set Atlas I
think needs to get credit in this Creek
get credit first we'll set Atlas to be
all other m ft atlas equals texture
Atlas no that's not it it's yeah thing
is just texture Atlas its creator
something surely I'll create sure oh
let's just um I don't think it's new way
is free type - is storage this isn't
very long Sir Richard haven't you knew
maybe it isn't you knew yeah it isn't
you okay - tag so texture Atlas new so
we'll make it like 512 512 so the depth
is the bit depth all that into one right
now which means it will output into one
channel we probably want to do garage
you people will play around with this in
a minute but we'll set it to one for now
so I think what that means is it will
output it into the red Channel we'll
take a look at the source code of
freedive GL in a minute and confirm that
but that's what I think it does okay so
now let's begin rendering it so the
first thing we need to do is actually
bind the texture so we probably need a
font so MFT font equals three x yep
so this atlas is literally just a
texture atlas so it's like a sprite
shade or a form shade right except it's
going to dynamically generate that based
on what we need rather than just having
bitmap font which is static and it's
what we do beforehand and we're very
limited by it right so this will
generate stuff so when we do something
like texture font known as the type
texture creates forms new font that your
fonts know let's just pop in here and
see what it is okay so under class for
you
we will probably find under the
namespace that your font T this is so
useless oh here we go
texture font new from file Atlas size
file and size is the size of the fonts
endpoints fantastic so text your font
new from file that's exactly what we
want - your font new from file so we'll
need to specify the file it wants the
Atlas first so there's the Atlas sorry
it's m FG Atlas it wants the size so
we'll say like size 24 now we should
have some way of doing this again we
should have a font manager probably not
gonna do that right now but the file
name again we'll just go Ariel dort ETF
and we'll actually get it in a minute
and said that that's as far doesn't
exist yet obviously we'll make it exist
there okay now that we've got all that
stuff the big thing we need to do is
this Atlas as I mentioned is a text show
it's just an OpenGL texture in fact
that's what free times yeah will do it
will basically get the pixels and put
them into a and OpenGL Tasha so what we
need to do is find our texture code
which is this this is like our texture
code and we'll just pop that into here
so the T ID which is the OpenGL kind of
ID that we want to do sorry that's yes
let's see yeah we would be so we don't
need that because it's going to be
greater than zero clearly we'll
definitely have a texture every time
when we're entering a font so this T ID
right just becomes MFT atlas dot dot ID
right that's it so do we need to do this
every time
no we don't we only need to do that per
font right because once it's bound and
whatnot we know that we don't have a
texture manager right now which is why
I'm doing it this way we're going to
sorry file manager we're going to
eventually have one it's just that it's
going to it's not something I want to
erase right away I just want to get this
stuff working first obviously so okay
cool so what we will do is yeah so we'll
go ahead and create this stuff so so we
we have so all we need to do now is a
few things we need to query
free type GL for the appropriate vector
sorry vertex positions and sizes
obviously which is just vertex positions
and texture coordinates very important
again this atlas is just a big map of
fonts so this atlas just to give you an
idea of what it will look like in fact
let's just render it let's do that
that'll be fantastic so what we'll do
right now is this drawstring all it will
do is it will go through let's just grab
a bunch of code so this is what we need
to render something
UV so let's have this two back to zero
one all right yeah
we'll go ahead and set up set this up
oops Wyatt what's that that's Siri
one-on-one right yeah okay color doesn't
really need to be a thing yeah it
doesn't this is just a test so we can
say this stuff vertex okay let's quickly
set this up sir maths victory zero zero
zero
it probably needs like I said me a
daughter or something system go like 8
or negative 8 this is actually
okay fantastic so there we go that's
it's just that's rendering this huge
thing
tid will be TS which is that thing we
need to make sure that yeah so we're
doing that great
that should work so now we actually need
to add some clips so what so this right
now will probably be just this empty big
thing so if I does I don't even know
well that's not going to be wrong right
now because it's not being called
anywhere but inside layer that's EBP if
I go ahead and just Millea I go ahead
and just go ahead and do M render a
drawstring so texts will just be flying
it as a matter of us say we're not we're
just pretending
okay so inside here okay
so inside here we will just say again
what is it it's like yes if we run this
right now we should just have a black
blob thing or something yep so there's
our texture right now it's blank if it's
even working
hopefully it is so if we go ahead and
we'll see in a minute um if we go ahead
and say F DGL texture I think it's
loaded pull here for something all gasp
cliff why are you so annoying um there's
something to do with cliff that's our
actual type okay one thing we can do by
the way is if you right-click on this
scroll bar thing you know the scroll
area doesn't review the bar and you go
scroll bar options you can use map mode
which is really cool so you can see them
now transform to map mode and you can
actually see the code and you can even
hover your mouse over and see Leah so
that's a useful thing that I forgot to
set up in this version of Visual Studio
because we didn't really need it but now
it's useful um so font get glyph right
so back out here Tasha font get cliff so
what it want it wants the font like
guessing that is so FG font and then it
wants the character code so if we go
like I want a and we run this okay
that's a problem what is that exactly
okay let's just break and load symbols
so some kind of assertion is happening
somewhere in font in three times you
yell okay so I said it self so self is
not what - your font t Monty oh of
course so the font doesn't exist how
about you tell me that it doesn't exist
instead of being like Lowell okay so
we've got to actually load fonts so
let's go ahead and just click the Start
menu type in font go fonts find any font
you like such as Arial copy that going
to go into your Sparky well this will be
I'll push this to get up but go into
Sparky you just play it cool and just
paste it into here there'll be a few of
them we only want Ariel just the normal
Ariel - there yo don't know you can see
what it looks like cool let's run this
again we should get that okay cool so
there you go and you can see that up
here we've got a little letter A again
predictably is written right on the red
channel as I said it would be but there
it is
so the cool thing is if we add a bunch
of characters and it's not going to
start really packing them but if we if
we add like random anything any
character really then you can see that
it now has all those guy and you can see
it is actually packing them good let's
turn off this lighting where is my Frank
there's my flag
so let's just come at that
yeah so you can see that it's ok it's
quite small let's hop into close some of
these things we don't need any of them
into here and I'll just boost the size
so it's 20 right now let's make it like
80 or something you can see how it's
packing them so a is all aligned up
there and it's basically it's doing them
in such a way that it takes up the
minimum amount of room the minimum
amount of room required okay so taking
up a lot of room
that's what it's doing so this is what
it looks like so now what we need to do
is we need to do a few things we need to
construct we need to construct our like
actual geometry right we need to
actually construct a bunch of sprites
essentially that feel that are the
correct size you can see if that
explanation mark is for example much
narrower than this letter B all right we
need to and I'm sure if you like you
know what let's add a glyph it's really
small like a dolt for example that's a
good idea
now we're really testing it I wonder if
it'll pack it up to Mele mm not exactly
let's see well as well come on yeah see
oh well yeah kind of not really yeah so
there you go you can see it's packing it
very optimally but the idea is we want
to make a sprite that is the right size
and wheat this is this is just one
texture so we need to adjust the texture
coordinates this might be like 0.1 you
write the youth - ordinate we might want
to yeah so we'll we'll need to work out
what direction corners we want to use
and what vertex positions we want to use
to construct our sprite we need to do
all that so this is where the fun begins
and you could say that the fun never
ends but anyway this is obviously nice
this tax reform get glyph we don't want
to do that for everything we could we
totally could load all of them here
that might be the best way to do it so
you can do something like for cha
unsigned char whatever I'm going this is
solar code cha equals like the first one
I don't know what that is I don't think
it's a it might be a C is less than the
last character which I have no idea what
that is let's just say might be question
it's not question mark but legislators
and then you could just texture you
could do this essentially for C right
and there we go and that would load all
your clips so you can do something like
that
because of course these are just
integers these things these characters
so you could do something like that
instead you could dynamically load the
one you actually need them so we can do
that that'll it's probably that's
probably the simplest way so we know
this string tax we need to render each
of these so let's go ahead and loop
through it that is probably the the good
first step to so for in C I'll call it
I'll call it I because I'll have see in
a minute so less than text of length I
plus plus so so cha will extract the
character so chassis make sure it's a
reference otherwise you'd be copying it
equals text i right so we're getting the
appropriate okay let's get rid of the
Const
that's a bit annoying um goodbye Const
and goodbye Const okay
so we've got the character now we just
want to basically create the glyph so
what is it it's texture font get cliff
font is m3 type fonts character code is
C oh yeah so I could have used text on
ass I that's one thing I probably should
have mentioned so we can probably
restore constant right
maybe not
okay so we could do this instead we
could put we could restore the
consonants this is just such a neat
picky thing but we could restore the
constants and just drop the reference
anyway
let's so if so kay we need so we need to
actually get a cliff so texture glyph T
maybe yes totally
so if glyph is null which if you
actually read the documentation for
funky cliff you would see that it
returns it requests a new clip from the
font and if it hasn't McCready it will
be so it will create it
if this isn't null so sorry I should say
it will be created automatically we
don't need to manually be like I'm gonna
grate this obviously we didn't have to
for the other example but if it is null
it means we might we might have
requested a character that the font
doesn't have okay so for example not all
not all fonts would have like smiley
faces or other ASCII characters right no
other just yeah
general characters so that's why we need
to check for null and make sure it's not
null so if so we need to do okay so
let's go ahead and do this where is our
code oh here it is okay good so let's
take one example of this yeah well we
what we want to do is we want to set
this we want to set these up so float X
0 will be so X plus so X is our our
offset what like so positioned on X is
actually what it is so position dot X so
we'll have to say float X 0 will be so
we'll have four of these they're
basically coordinates right plus the
glyph offset X right same for y and then
width and height basically so
x1 y1 which will be X 0 which is the
other vertex position plus cliff width
that's the thing good and height okay
now when you do the texture coordinates
so I don't know why copy that I guess I
could have just copy this oops so s and
T we can just use U and V I'll probably
make more sense
UV okay so s T is also used by the way
you can use s T instead of Peavey's up
to you so this is easy this is really
easy we just go cliff yeah the reason I
wanted to do it is because this this
kind of uses s and T but all right we'll
deal with it so U is U is T obviously an
S sorry u is s and these T anyway there
you go so these are and again this just
gives so this is the first normalize - a
coordinate X of top left corner it does
this stuff for us that's why we're using
texture
sorry that's why we're using font GL
sorry free type GL and not gels free
time because if we were to be using free
time we have to work all this stuff out
and that's madness and we don't want to
do that it's already been done so anyway
now that we've done this we can begin
setting this stuff so we need to
construct the vector 3 from basically x0
so this is the first one of y0 0
the UV of course will be maths vector u0
v0 so since so since the one thing I
should mention is since our oh and this
clearly should be that by the way well
but one thing I should mention is since
our projection matrix is set up so that
positive Y is in the upward direction we
should use negative
hide here okay anyway um where's
everything happening yeah so our tid is
TS and everything else is good now the
Cullowhee you set up obviously as well
so I don't know what comes doesn't the
order doesn't matter I'm just doing this
for a second code color a cold color I
think that we can just set that right
why is it color oh okay where's our code
so let's talk about the color yeah
we will definitely switch to using UN's
permanently because it's a terrible idea
to not do that
really but I mean that falls are the
simpler option but this is just I like
using UN's for color anyway and those of
you who are following a lot more like
game programming and 3d and programming
would know this it's just much easier to
do that
well it's not much easy but that's what
I do there all time anyway that's our
first one let's do it for the other ones
and then very important that you don't
forget this index count at the end
because sorry not at the end at the end
of this because each character is going
to take up that many indices okay
so x0 and next one's going to be I think
up so we'll just take Y one and that one
and then we'll have both as one and then
we'll have just the X okay that's it
done I don't know what will happen if we
try and do this that's just well I got a
bunch of things but let's just run that
and see nothing okay let's stop
rendering where's our lair let's start
rendering this so that we can actually
see things okay we're getting nothing
that's all right
so what is going on
let's just step through this first of
all so the texture shouldn't be failing
we know that much so the color is zero
well that I would say that's the problem
we are rendering into the Reg you know
what okay let's get into our shader real
quick I think we might be doing
something wrong in the shadow so for the
sake of this I'm just going to output
say whites okay it's just not here all
that's interesting let's take a look at
let's just step through this and and
check it out
so whatever we can skip through that cuz
we know that works could we tested it
already so ts is like one that's fine
okay what oh why don't rendering any
text lulls sorry hello what oh excuse me
okay
that a shader error yes potentially it
looks like it that's weird
what's causing it I wonder okay let's
step through this
right that's that's wrong method okay
okay cool so first character is H get
cliff cliff retrieved let's scare it
that space it's going to do all oh my
goodness
shouldn't have gotten rid of the thing
x0 y0 yep
so you can see those those UV is a very
finely calculated take out the right
amount of stuff yep
72 oh he'll our walls
not that wouldn't have worked or
anything but it that was wrong anyway
everybody that's maybe why I complained
no probably want it why the 1280 wanting
me okay one thing I should mention let's
just quickly say we if we even even
touch the offset a little bit so if we
go back into well I guess if we did do
mmm-hmm let's head into I think we are
actually walking I think it's just um
mmm no one else damn okay so something's
up that doesn't matter
so 1281 is definitely going from there
right no it's not what
well this is weird
we broke something what did we break I
know I mean wait hang on we broke
something
12:31 is invalid value I think so that's
not be no that's not broken clearly did
I taught you anything else know one
thing we should do this is not this is
not part of that problem that we should
do it anyway is that again not part of
our problem but we should be doing it so
this is taking position to acts and
everything all but it might be
let's quickly just do this
okay okay so okay yeah that it seems to
be working okay sorry let's change this
back let's go into our shader and let's
revert that to text color we don't need
our intensity let's not go that far
okay cool so there we go and it's a
putting in reddit so we I don't know
what that thing is but it looks like our
characters a bit oversized so which
probably fixed that so the reason that's
happening is because if you actually
take a look at this in closer detail
you'll see that this is like one or
whatever and then this is like 58 and
clearly our like entire projection
matrix has a I got an entire like height
I guess from clipping plane to clipping
plane of 18 so that's just ridiculous
so we've got a few things that we wanted
to namely we want to probably have some
kind of scale okay so this should
probably be set by layer or something so
we could have something like float this
is obviously terrible but say oh say our
width is like we know that it's 960 it's
probably rendering it in that kind of
space because it's just rasterizing
pixels and our I'll like span from clean
final nice negative State deposit of 16
which is 32 so we could do something
like this scale X and then scale Y this
isn't going to say it for long clearly
because it only works with this one
projection matrix but 18 and then all we
would have to do is be like with offset
X let's divide that by that width and
height let's divide that by our scale
okay and then everything else should be
fine so if we look at this it should be
normal-sized now okay it is now I
characters seem to be all on top of each
other that's not good probably because
we haven't advanced it at all so if we
go into so our X is our position right
so we should this is actually quite
similar to the position axis oh that's
conference mother duck
let's make in x equals position X here
okay
so X plus equals I think it's just
belief advance X yes so make sure we
divide that by a scale this is actually
quite similar to the font rendering
episode in game programming so you might
want to watch that if you want more
detail on how to actually do this from a
bitmap font since we're using freetype
here instead but you can see that it
kind of works it's a touch weird I mean
it did okay we probably need to set the
kerning as well so I love coding doesn't
anyone doesn't everyone love car did I
really make that an integer hang on a
minute
and that was problem
we should definitely set kerning as well
so the way you can do that is so kerning
of courses have applied for not the
first character but from now on so what
we need to do is we basically need to be
like let's get our coding so that's I
think it's just clear text should live
get care yeah fantastic
so M free type font character code is
safe is it yeah so why you mad bro oh
sorry it's for a cliff and the character
code is actually a text
apps
we can just use text I minus one okay
and okay there's our coding and then all
we have to do is be like X plus equals
caning now you might have to scale it
appropriately as well I'm not sure that
was pretty good though let's try and
divide this by X scale sorry scale X
yeah I don't know kerning is coding
probably doesn't need to it's gonna be
quite a tiny value if it once it gets
divided so if we take a look at this
oops it's well at zero we haven't really
set that up either some fonts will
probably have that we should support
that anyway okay the point is we are
pretty much ready to roll except and
everything seems to be working I mean if
we change the font size to be small for
example so like eight or something
that'll be really hard to see but you
know you can see that if I blow it up
it's gonna be blurry but it's rendering
very well like it's still it's still
readable and it's totally the best and
if I similarly if I blow it up to like
200 there yeah that totally works as
well so we've got very good font
rendering now so a few things that are
problematic first of all it seems to be
outputting our color in red why is that
well glad you asked because if we take a
look at the the code to I think a weak
done I think we're done like in terms of
actual font rendering so we can focus on
this stuff now and fine tune it in
what I want to see has in texture Atlas
I think it is yes so if the we if we set
the depth to one as we did it's going to
as you can see GL text image 2d into
jail red okay which means it's going to
pop it into the red channel which means
that the red channel if we go into our
fragment shader the red channels was
going to have everything the red channel
laser pulls this all X right so if we go
back for say zero zero and then just the
red Channel and then one for alpha then
it will be blue right yeah pretty cool
one thing we should do is also enable
this this will make our stuff black and
white by the way but which will go into
layer and whoops and enable these
because we'll say that there's probably
no transparency either okay cool so well
not only not black and white um blue is
what I meant blue and white I guess um
anyway yes so you can see that there's
no this isn't transparent at all so the
reason it's not transparent is because
what will you really should be doing is
instead of setting it to the blue
channel we should be setting it to the
Alpha Channel and then this will be our
color okay so it's a bit hard to do this
and then I guess it was not that hard
here's what we'll do we'll go back to
layer we'll disable this and then back
in our fragment shader will set this to
like a colors as our one might want to
render in pink so that's the pink right
the Alpha set to say the red channel so
we could've just used alphabet anyway in
main I'm going to set the clay call it
to something like Y to perhaps and you
should see that we don't have any
problems like it's totally not working
sorry
this comes down to blending modes now so
this is this is actually working this is
what it looks like without the textures
because the textures there's no such
thing as transparency unless we enable
Blanding so we have to go into say
window so where's a window window that
is surprisingly not helpful at all there
we go
and then when we've yeah so say once
OpenGL is up and running we can probably
go GL enable we don't even have do we
even have like death test and they will
probably not anyway Jill blend okay and
then we can sense but the blend function
to GL sauce alpha which is the Alpha of
the source and then GL one minus source
alpha
so that'll subtract our source alpha
from one so if you want more details on
those you can google blend functions and
actually see what the functions do but
it's just senses like the blood function
okay so if we're on this now it should
be okay
well not oh what's that
there we go so you can see now we're
totally legit and it doesn't matter what
our background is if I drop that and
it's suddenly like teal ish whatever
it's you can see if the transparency is
still there so fantastic we've got that
now and it's looking pretty good
now here's where things get complicated
what if I do want to have let's remember
we want to render both the font and the
the font and the sprites and everything
all in the batter Ender are using one
shader okay which is like our
general-purpose shader thing obviously
we can have custom shaders such as for
the lighting but we don't really need
that for fonts in one mark so how do we
just use Mon shader because obviously
this is a very special case here that we
need to set for the font so we could do
something like split up draw calls or
have attributes and pass uniforms and oh
my goodness that would we could totally
have an attribute that's like any
integer or something or a bully and it's
just like it's is font um but that would
be not that would be terrible we don't
want to do that that's just that's not
really correct so instead we can kind of
be smart about things if we look at this
this looks ridiculous but you can say
that transparency is totally the best so
we do still want to basically let's
restore what it was before which was
just text color one thing we should do
by the way is less tend to be a thing so
if we go into here right now if a
texture is selected text the color which
is FSM McCullough has absolutely zero
effect on anything so we want to just
say that let's let it still affect our
texture so here on this now this looks
ridiculous right now because it's
incorrect if we go into what is
renderable 2d no sprite
then you'll see that we're sending it to
pink as the default color let's set it
to one okay uh let's change the clayey
color to black
okay so we've lost all of our textures
it seems that's weird let's go back here
is that because of the color it'll be
weird if it was Oh what oh well this is
now how you can see how that light is
just not blending why later but anyway
um that's fine because it's affecting
alpha uh that's what we add third why
did we that should be one that should be
little one so just be one of times Oh
cuz it's black so it is black let's
let's head out here for a second oh okay
I think it's because I think it's
because in our batch renderer
all I'm doing is attention please
all I'm doing inside here is setting it
okay so I'm Allison yet so let's not
else this this should be always
happening so it'll be just hitting white
okay there we go now we've got this we
totally lost our texture weird stay one
of this oh no we didn't have a text okay
good because I was about to say whoa
let's so now we're doing at this in
color cool
so we let's quickly look at this yes
there's our text but if we do do FSM
color then it totally lose everything we
are rendering keep in mind we are
rendering the text apparently black or
some ridiculous thing but said it's just
white
okay there we go so we're rendering our
text everything was good it's not white
it's black and it's got some weird stuff
going on but that's another story by the
way but like the whole lighting thing
which we won't open that now but I will
quickly just disable that so we can
actually see what it looks like okay so
we've lost how blending now because of a
few reasons but really it's just it's
not it's not our correct color so we're
in this unfortunate scenario where we
can't really like we can't really even
control what's going on with this
because of the way that free type GL set
up so we probably need you modify three
times yell I I don't know actually I was
kind of planning on this working so what
he'll want how long have we been going
for a while an hour and a half next
episode is optimization episode I don't
don't sure if I want I get like a I'll
just do it okay I'll just do it because
a lot um does coming up soon we don't
have much time so I've never done this
before so I've never looked for you to
have it all so hopefully this will be
not bad let's take a look at the atlas
and see how it set up so stuff it's got
a lot of asserts that's for sure
okay so let's just try changing this to
say it gel alpha so now it's on the
Alpha Channel instead of the red Channel
it's yeah pretty much gone so you can
see now the blending is working with
lighting but it's a bit weird I don't
know why the line is on get out
you've probably also noticed that it
wasn't white or any color that we really
specified it was black so we can get
black films rendering with never alone
in the Alpha but
the other thing is by the way our alpha
is being affected by the intensity of
light so alpha is stuff will become
transparent if the light is further away
it's terrible we should shouldn't be
doing that but anyway out in batch
render what was I doing
yes our color so our color wasn't light
out it was white if we just say pink or
whatever it's not gonna it's basically
still gonna be black so we can't set
color the way that we would like to
basically that's how that's our problem
right now so what we could do instead is
probably so we still need to store color
there's a few things we could do mmm
that's what so GL alpha so what we could
do is use GL like a luminance for
example let's try that I don't see what
happens okay that's so we get pink but
again we lose that stuff so we really
wanted to use luminance alpha but we if
it's just going to one channel that's
hmm probably not gonna work out too well
oh yeah so that's kind of good but it's
not at all so we're getting somewhere
so we probably want to use a luminance
alpha is you let's add it a new mode
that does this so else if def it's two
so we'll change this back to jail red
and then we'll change this to lumens
alpha and it'll still remain in ansan
bottom one also this obviously it's of
like luminance al from one rod takes up
more than just one byte per like pixel
basically so that's why we get problems
and that was actually really weird I
probably would have expected it to crash
but he didn't so lulz let me just think
so too okay
let's go into batch render and we'll use
mode two so we've made a new mode enum
and font in free type GL okay so we're
getting assertion looks like okay so
let's add our down equals two in here
and whoa okay cool
so surprisingly that's actually pretty
good apart from you know everything else
but it's time to probably fix this up so
texture atlas new right now we're
allocating um so how's this is this
sialic okay so it's it's so self dot
data so this is out this is those are
our pixels right so it looks like we're
allocating
that should be alright actually said
region so what is in here I wish I had
like visual as its outline something was
like so that region looks important
okay so this purpose probably sets it up
there's a bunch of assertions we don't
care about that and it looks like it
will just go ahead and basically copy a
bunch of pixels into self data so the
source is in that and the size of that
and then the destination is this so it's
copying a bunch of self into self data
which is our pixels so this is probably
what does it so we need to basically be
like let's have extra stuff in here so I
don't know how we're going to do this
but let's make let's make a knot whoa
let's make J here hmm
so the plan the plan is that we want to
so we need to set the first byte of
every pixel to be white space or foot
like full so 255 so I guess we'll just
okay so we'll say if so if our depth
wishes self-taught depth which is up
here is 2 right which is our margin so
we'll keep we'll keep doing until we
weren't completely destroy this in case
someone decides and Sparky to actually
using its margin so if a def is full
we'll have
okay so ro and source
so we'll say drawer equals and this is
going to be the tricky part because we
need to get the correct actually it's
probably just that and then the source
is what we're copying from which is just
that I think and the spacing though
come on okay so now we'll say J equals
zero J is less than with the J plus plus
J times two plus zero okay so yeah so
we're making room for extra bytes
essentially and we're going to just say
so
so what we've done is just a quick
explanation because I don't even know if
this is going to work but hopefully well
we're allocating basically double the
amount of space so depth is now two
instead of one so where it used to be
where we were getting this much time
size of that but now we're allocating
twice as much
twice as many bytes and there's going to
be an extra byte that holds our
luminance alpha so that like LM is alpha
was basically made out of two bytes now
instead of one so we had yell read
before which was just one byte which it
was just the red Channel and it was like
kind of like a it was just yeah again I
was just in one channel now we've got
luminance though so this will be just
full right so 255 or zero x FF if you
want to be all cool and hexadecimal and
then we'll set the offset at one so I'm
just doing this plus zero stuff to make
it more apparent in the code we'll just
be
I think so salsa J lulz hmm that will
work
build it so let's just what okay sir
okay so there just looks like it's being
cut off a link that's not bad
hmm
mmm let's say that if our death is true
we'll set it through one because I think
I think our dad's stuff will break a lot
of other stuff oh my goodness
is this real life I think that works no
I think it's just aligned with that holy
guacamole
okay let's 0 0 0 well it appears that we
are in action
yes fantastic so yeah I mean okay cool
I'm just thinking if there's anything
else that I missed I don't think so yeah
so the problem with the depth I was was
that was that all the widths were
getting calculated wrong because there
wasn't a case for death tickles too so
we should just be able to still use the
same spacing and all of that stuff for
fonts that are like this but with
luminance alpha we can basically as you
can see use the same shader and the same
system to get that stuff to work so so
yay
um okay so let's go into here and play
around with a few of the settings
battery under up so we'll change this is
to permanently now we'll change this to
like 80 or something a good example will
really be to be like okay so what's a
what's a good open source file I'm just
gonna ask the stream what's a good open
source font I'm sure our Ariel's I
probably can't I probably can't like
probably not up for licensing whatever
like as in license it's probably not
free if anyone knows of a good open
source form that I can just upload to
github along with this we'll do that
but if we go out into layer and stop
doing this stuff for a minute I don't
know why we're doing all that stuff in
there let's let's expose this properly
in the API so we've got labels now right
and labeled we'll call drawstring right
so we should just be able to say
layup ad okay so I'm just looking at
this stream so if you'll be able to
saying I should use source sans Pro so
I'll use that so that looks free it was
in Adobe font okay cool so I'll use that
in a minute but so new new label let's
include level
so text is we can do something like we
need to set text and whatnot
here's what we'll do we'll pop into
label quickly and we'll just move this
into public and pull it text and yeah
X&Y and whatever you know what I'm just
going to do this it is better
so in labels here we'll set position
position doesn't matter and color but
what if people try and get the position
they shouldn't if that's why I don't
really want to promise I just say
position is a thing I could do this
right I could just say you'll see what
I'm doing
so I'm going to make a maths because I
just don't want ambition obviously they
can't be I suppose really that's going
to be a reference totally don't like
apparently this isn't oh that's not a
thing anymore
there we go so now you'll see my plan
label FPS so we're going to print FPS
because why not let's finally do that a
new label we don't need to really
specify text yet I'll just say FPS for
now why don't it doesn't matter
um I don't know zero zero for now color
that's the only annoying thing
let's what's a good color white I don't
know pink who knows
so we've got that now let's add that
then what we want to do is say
FPS so text equals FPS register STD to
string FPS which will make in a minute
plus that that should totally work right
that's not thing
not so FPS probably isn't a thing yeah
that's probably wise F into F F equals
frames last angle it is how this works
okay it does cool there we go there we
got got our yes now just being displayed
as phones totally looks like a frame
right took a bit of a plummet actually
I'm not sure why that is hopefully we
didn't do anything to her
that's a massive fault by the way
so let's just yeah we don't need to give
it any text to begin with to be honest
so zero zeros bad location and also
let's
my god just said it frames what was I
doing
sorry I'm quite tired today I apologize
for this lengthy video um all the waking
the fallen small sorry
like 30 32 no that's that's probably a
good size so let's get rid of so the
reason I had that set up is because if
it wasn't label if we were actually
calling drawstring we would actually
need F but we can just use frames
because if I guess that one for a second
anyway what I'm saying is if this was if
this was outside we would need to have F
that's what that was my thinking behind
that
okay let's position that a bit better
so yeah but the idea is we can change
our position and whatnot so I could be
like position FPS our position top X
plus plus and every second it will just
advance poom poom-poom pretty cool so
that's that was just a cool little trick
as well to get it to do that because it
was um yeah it was something else and
then I just made a reference to it cuz I
wanted it to be cold position I wanted
it to be public anyway now that we've
done that um let's get rid of most of
these things so I think we're pretty
good um one thing I wanted to do a bit I
don't remember anymore let's set this to
like 15 and you could say it's relative
to how thing as well
and like eight I don't know that's gone
yeah that was way too that's harsh let's
just set it there that should be alright
I should be like left yeah there is oh
my still
x+ flossing 15.5 let's just set it to
black because oh we could we could make
um here's what we could do if we want to
be cool we could make a group which has
a matrix so we can pass in probably main
constructor that just takes in a victory
as well but we can pass in so what do we
get what are we come up with negative
five point five maybe seven point five
zero right we can add the label to the
group
and just set this to like 0.5 0.5 so
this is why I wanted it to be in the
same render everything is not what I had
in mind at all
we're transformations stacking right oh
well well adding FPS another group okay
good so we're up there now um that's
15.8 and that looks like it should be
lower yeah that's good and then what we
could do again is since we're in the
group and one on we can just be like
group dot add new sprite zero zero the
width and high so whatever not that it
has away tonight but we could set it
with the fire within higher like to two
or something that's ridiculously wrong
so maybe I don't know and then color can
be something like I don't know cool
that's cool and it's probably going to
write no water that's alright and when
we sing that so that's probably guys
rendering older I'll actually no it's
not
so there we go that's wrong but almost
right yeah anyway you can see that we
have this kind of situation where we if
we wanted a background for the FPS for
example that is possible and let's have
the caulobacter like white
oh you know what I'm like gray but
almost white no I know all right there
we go
pretty cool so I'll make this like five
or something okay cool
so anyway you can see that you can do
something like that because they're
being rendered by the same thing and
everything is just really cool so that
is the idea in fact I might make this oh
and and now that we've got blending
actually you can be like a 0.5 F alpha
and are you ready for your mind to be
blown look at that transparency pretty
cool so that's awesome so yeah you can
do some of that and that's totally ok
the FPS okay cool anyway that's pretty
much it so let's grab this font what it
looks like
one thing I wanted to point out quickly
though is yeah this does work with
everything else so let's obviously try
it with Comic Sans the best item in the
universe and also consult like a cool
font as well so we'll get rid of that so
console ah I guess which is just yeah
okay I know what mm sorry this is just
fantastic
Lord comic and should just work the Alps
you see our FPS is now in Comic Sans
let's draw one more text thing as well
so maybe
later add new label hello world
zero zero will be fine maths fact four
one zero zero there are one I might just
make the font bigger just like it's fine
you guys can see
so there's Comic Sans notes
okay you guys can't see because it's
tiny in fact you know what I'll do I'll
quickly just in main I'll get rid of
this and I'll make this flight be so
much easier to see and then I'll just
make this so we definitely need some
kind of file manager will do that may be
upset 21 will see 82 so there it is
there's Comic Sans hello world minus 5
ok fantastic and then if we wanted to
consult with so consult la apparently
then
there you go cool so totally the best
and it will do all the nice symbols that
exist that's cool anyway that is the
general idea so then let's grab this
source sans pro I guess we'll grab the
source code release thing let's just go
into here and see what's up Roman
maybe we regular I guess I don't know
fault of GFF let's click on that view
rule it's gonna last
let's just run download for us that's
fantastic it's exactly what I wanted
let's grab that go into Sparky will
delete all the illegal fonts source sans
Pro let's look at it yeah that looks
pretty good
that's fine what does the light one I
usually like life once so let's look at
that one extra light just light that
doesn't look any lighter at all what oh
right they're both white what I don't
understand what's happening doesn't
matter we'll just use the one that we've
got so it's source sans Pro
okay so now you know what happens when
it can't load characters what what why
you why you what
why did that happen this is interesting
soul sounds prior also maybe the light
one was a bit lighter actually because
this isn't one that's so weird
let's look at download it real quick so
this was regular no that's now light so
I must have deleted the other one or
something but no they're the same
whatever okay so what exactly happened
though why is it failing um
soul sounds bro that's that's it well
it's definitely loading the file because
if I wasn't loading the file it be well
that um some ugly-ass earthing
mmm odd let's hmm let's quickly look at
this
where are we here we are so I'm guessing
cliff is just returning null or
something you know but it's not see it's
not returning null because it can't be
otherwise I wouldn't be rendering the
character at all so well that's control
f11 I didn't mean to seven just assembly
I mean today it shifted 11 mm-hmm so
it's not null it's just it's just weird
and that's like it's just like oh I know
what the offset is I know what's going
on that's so weird
let's
hmm let's try change again into an
OpenType phones don't know that will do
anything no it's a hater
it is a hater let's try sir Roman
masters what's that I don't know what
this is that's not what we want
let's try light why they'll called font
T - yeah like seriously don't have a
better name oops it looks like the same
one really confused as to why this isn't
working
well I guess we'll look at out all of
these open source well
source code Pro that's cool
she'll yeah
download the fonts latest release souls
card on Herman was so scared but okay
fine
longest episode ever again yeah okay
TGIF please okay let's just take light
there we go so we add I that's a hideous
font maybe we should have just
downloaded the other one maybe maybe you
didn't download it probably because I
hit few roll or something soul sands pro
that's what we wanted right laces it's
alright
that's that that's a very bad I do not
like that fun wool look at it it's weird
it's bad not cool
like it there it doesn't actually look
that bad here so maybe it's just my
phone rendering maybe it's just on blind
it should a little exam there's else
though so yeah I don't like that I'm not
a fan of those owls like that looks good
anyway let's not talk about oh it's got
that nice dot in the zero as well I like
that are you done what was I downloading
stuff probably opened yes here it is so
TTFN
light please so if this doesn't work
it's that's gonna be weird
hey okay I don't know why it didn't work
for bit it works now so let's change the
size back to like 32 and yeah it looks
pretty good let's make it wise okay
because I don't like that great color i
what is white is it that doesn't look
very white to me oh no wait now that's
why it but that isn't I was going to say
okay there we go
so there's our FPS everything is
fantastic hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of font rendering of course
let's turn everything else back on
so you can grant labels drawstring might
be a thing in the future but right now
you can just create labels and that's
definitely the best thing to do I think
oh I know what's going on right all
right it's weird why is our alpha sore
like I don't know it just looks kind of
that's fine there we go all right cool
so hope you guys enjoy this episode if
you did please hit the like button and
I'll see you next time next time it's
going to be a nice relaxed episode in
which we're going to just maintance go
through all the github issues so one
final reminder is to go to github.com
for saffiano under Sparky if you want
you can open in issue here I'm going to
go all through up through all the next
episode which I think will be on
Saturday those of you watching live
stream and we'll probably refactor a
bunch of things and fix it up so if you
guys enjoyed this video please hit like
button I'll see you guys next time
goodbye